From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning Mr. Anderson. It's a pleasure to be with you. Thank you for welcoming us to your home this morning.
My name is Joe Winnier of the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
We're here in Bogolusianne to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian, specifically the Smithsonian's Museum of African American History and Culture.
I am with colleague John Bishop, who is our videographer and the project curator from the National Museum.
Ms. Lane Nichols is here as well. We are in Bogolusa with Mr. Fletcher Anderson and Mrs. Cynthia Anderson to talk about the movement and the deacons in the 50s, 60s and talk about all that history.
Thank you again. It's going to be worth it. Thank you.
I thought I'd start if I would like to just or both would like to just reflect a little bit about say Bogolus in the late 50s and early 60s sort of set the context for the more active phase of local struggle level of emerge in the 64-65 period.
I was first interested in coming from the cross burning that happened in the 6th, when the Cookega clan burned across the Nau Yacht.
That's really what got our attention to something was going on. From that point on, we definitely got involved with the Civil Rights Movement, making conditions better than what they were.
We were always aware that we were treated as second classes, but we were kind of in a fix where it was acceptable. But that we saw things changing and the rest of the world in laws begin to change.
We wanted to be a part of that change. And that cross burning come about because when I went to work at the Barf Act in 1962.
And then when I went to work at the Barf Act in 1962, they had separate everything, separate bathrooms, separate drinking fountain, separate doors that you go through to go into the Yacht, separate paylines, separate working places.
So I and some more of the employees were there wanting to make a difference. And first I started as a new employee, the black employees that were previously there had me to do things that they wouldn't do because I was a new employee as a new no better.
So I would go and drink out the water fountain attempt to take showers in a white bathroom. But for that bathroom because I would be turned around.
The water fountain that they found up and say, you're not supposed to do that. Well, the oldest black employee knew that I wasn't supposed to do that. It wasn't allowed. But since I was a new employee, they kind of had me to test that.
And at that point, we started filing lawsuits against our workplace. And we went to court along with the Robert Hicks, he filed a suit and we were just for the end of the suit. We all had to testify and fairly courted about our working condition.
And from that point, things kind of opened up at the workplace concerned. We were able to work on job that black said never been able to work on.
And we were able to get our black females employed at that plant, which had never happened before. And we were able to get supervisors in the plant that had never been before.
And this is when things really start getting heated up because that's the changes that they have never happened before. And sometimes changes hard to come back.
Because people get what's said in their own ways and get white employees that didn't want to make a change that they didn't want to see this happen.
So things got to be hard and sticky as we might say in Bogdallus. So that's when we left out of the plant, we got the plant pretty well situated but out in the streets in the community.
And we were able to get it. Things were talked about and it was heated. We were dealing with a city that didn't hire black city workers.
And on the garbage truck, we didn't have a black person working. We didn't have a black person working. There was no elected people on the council or any form of government inside of the city of Limit of Bogdallus.
And these are the changes that we went about trying these things that we went about trying to change. And about doing that, we had many, many marches in Bogdallus in the city of Bogdallus until this city courthouse.
And we end up having to go to federal court to try to get some of these obstacles removed. And then doing that, we had to testify in federal court. Then we had to get an injunction against the police department in Bogdallus.
They keep them from brutalizing the black people of the city of Bogdallus. And we had to go, I was one of the one had to go and testify in federal court to make these things happen. I was participate in all of the, most of the changes that happened inside of the city of Bogdallus in the surrounding areas.
We didn't have no black policeman. I had the opportunity to sit down with the negotiating committee that put other, it's abusive from the AFL, from St. Louis, Anna that come in. And I presented three names.
And out of those three names that I presented two of them was chosen to be the first black policeman of the city of Bogdallus.
Though three I presented with my classmates, the class of 1959, they also worked with me at the Barfract. And they were chosen to be the first black policeman of the city of Bogdallus.
And we had to get to injunction against the city of the police because they were terrorizing the black citizens of Bogdallus.
It was beating them as we were doing. So we went to court, we got to injunction so some of that ceased some of that seat.
And then we marched to Frankerton three times to try to get some things open up in the Paris.
We marched one time and they didn't know good. We marched the second time and they didn't know good. Then we said we're going to take it to the government, Governor John McKithey in Badenburg.
So we marched to Badenburg and at that particular time we didn't get chance to see the governor. He wasn't meet with. But they began to get so heated up.
Then he flew into Bogdallus and we had a meeting with him at the airport. And I was able to sit down and be a part of that meeting with him.
And we went on a lot of things and a few things opened up for us through that meeting.
But we kept the pressure on. We kept it. We kept marching. We kept picketing. We kept demonstrating. And men, a lot of more of the blacks we would picket marches to let them open up and give black people's job employment.
And as we kept pushing on them and the black quit shopping in their stores, they began to open up and high. And so we were successful there.
And most of the thing that we did, we were successful in open up employment for our people.
This is an interesting, do you want to have a little audience with us?
Yes, I'm a little bit.
It's a wonderful start. Thank you.
It will be a lot of history.
Sandy, do you want to start with some of your early recollections?
My first interest was when they burnt it, grossed a million.
Did you remember what happened?
Well, I know it was 63.
Yeah, about 63.
And when he left work, he was safe in the plant.
But when he left work between the plant and home, they would attack him. And they kept calling them Bob Hicks.
So he came home one evening and he said, come on, I want you to go with me.
I said, where are you going? I'm going to find out who this person I'm about to die for.
So we found out what they lived and we went to the Hicks's home.
You hadn't known them at that point?
I knew her.
But I had never had any kind of conversation or relationship with her.
And when we went, we got to their house and I walked into those, she asked me for my driver's license.
I gave him to.
And from that point, we were a team.
Yeah.
Man, ask a little bit, just a little bit more about the longer background.
Could you each say a little bit about your family and your parents?
Well, my grandfather was George Anderson.
My grandmother was Maggie Anderson.
And they were Spaniards and Bogdars.
They eventually came from Mississippi, which is a street Mississippi.
And they left street Mississippi and came to Bogdaluccia looking for a better opportunity and for workplace.
Because they had to paper me or here, they had to buy a factory here.
And they were looking for an employee.
My grandmother, she went into real estate.
And my grandfather, he ended up being a taxidrop in that was his employee.
He was one of the first black people to register vote and watch the parade.
And he was always active in civil rights.
And he had to help to elevate the blacks during that particular time.
He was very instrumental in helping that to come back.
My grandmother, she had a borders.
People that come into town, she roamed and boarded.
Rooms and fed them.
And they worked at these different jobs and embeholders.
And you were carrying bolus?
Oh, yeah.
Right, he had bolus.
Grandparents, they were really good finally.
They were property owners.
And my grandfather, he attended college.
My grandmother, she attended college.
And my mother was a very smart woman too.
But she was, my grandmother became ill and my mother singing after her.
That's basically what she did to care of her mother.
But they were wonderful, wonderful people.
And I married a sentient year baker.
And out of that reunion, we had three kids.
It was Sonia, Annison, Gamble, Annison, and Patrick, Annison.
And Sonia, she is blessed to have a wonderful daughter.
Gamble, she is blessed to have two wonderful grandchildren from him.
And they reside now in Dallas, Texas.
And my son, he is in Mount Harmon, Louisiana.
What did your grandparents go to college?
Oh, come.
My grandfather, what did Oh, come?
Purely.
This is actually, do you want to share some recollections of your family history?
Did you also grow up in the movies?
My history is my different from his.
My father was a Janine Lewis Baker senior.
And my mother was Esther V. Watson.
My mother was from Franklin, Louisiana.
My dad was from Zachary, Louisiana.
We grew up, I grew up in the middle quarters.
And we were considered the poets of the Black people.
We were outdoors, people, type people, we hunt, fish.
When I got in the seventh grade, my basketball coach told me to go ask my mom
to play basketball.
And when I went to talk to her, she didn't even turn around.
She said, yeah, as long as you make Donald Row.
I made Donald Row from then on.
I had a good life growing up in Vogue of Loosen when I found out how people really felt about me.
It hurt.
And then I wanted to fight back.
And when they disavigated the schools in 54, I had a whole group of girls ready to go on over to the high school
and take care of that little disavigation.
But the teachers liked to have a hard time.
Tell me a little bit about Mr. Armstrong, your decision to seek a job at the Vogue's factory.
And what your job was at factory and what it was like to work in there?
Yeah, when I first went there, my first job by working in the shipping department,
I was what you call a loader.
That's load in Vogue's car than trucks too.
And from that, I went to a trucker.
That's when you promoted to drive a folk rail and do the loadin' with folk rail.
And I left that and moved to another department which called the cargator.
And I went on a job there as a takeoff person.
And I moved from the takeoff person to a slitter operator.
And I moved from that to a first helpful.
And I left that position to go to an overhead crane operator.
And although the job will help prove to the head,
oh, but the takeoff person will help by white employees.
And I was able to work myself through that line and it wasn't easy.
Because when you really had to be trained by a person that you was going to eventually replace them.
And that's not easy. That's not easy for anybody to do.
You can imagine about how much training you would get.
So we basically had to basically train ourselves.
And the hard thing about when I went to the overhead crane operator,
I didn't have no training whatsoever.
I had to train myself on them.
And that's a dangerous job to overhead rail in the crane operator.
And that is the job that I basically got injured on,
probably the lack of training that I had to retire from.
But to get a change in that buffer,
I could go and not back to that workplace.
So we had to walk.
I had to walk in some of our other,
pick it on our own company.
And that's not easy.
Walk and pick it on your company.
And then you got to put your pick it down and punch in and go to work for the same people that you got there.
So you could imagine how to tension in the thing.
It was tough.
And we went on to,
I was wondering what I was thinking about when we went to the Meredith March,
when Jay Meredith got jumped on when he was going back to Ole Miss
for reunion of some sort.
And we were the acts as a deacons to come and protect the March.
And from the time that we got there,
we were able to march a man with no incident after that.
And that was during the time because we were very good at what we did protecting people.
We protected our neighborhoods that stopped people from driving by,
shooting up in the houses and beating them.
We had walker talkers.
We had come,
thing that commute with one another all through the community.
We know where everybody at.
We know we had block captains.
We had everything set or anything.
If anybody coming in there, we were able to block the streets up.
Because we had to be our own protection because the police were not there to protect us.
They were there to protect the crew crew.
How did you first hear about the deacons or become a member of the deacons?
First we were there sitting around and somebody came from Joan Burl.
And we were talking to us and I was in that meeting and it was talking about how they were able to form the solidification.
We become a charter member of it.
You had that very diverse meeting and that worried?
That's right.
It was with Joan Burl.
And it sounded pretty good to us.
Tell me what you remember from that meeting.
I think they were Ernest Thomas and Fred Kirkpatrick.
That's right.
And I remember sitting there on the many days explaining what they did in Joan Burl and how they did it and what we needed to do.
And from that meeting we just kind of bowed into it.
And then we just kind of set up our own deacon for defense.
And I was eventually kind of overshadowed there.
But it was a ridden that came from Joan Burl.
Had you grown up using a right-wing shotgun to hunt or how did you...
Yeah, we all been hunters.
We all been hunters.
We know how to hunt.
We know how to take care of weapons.
We know all of that.
But that's the honest reason.
I had never shot at a person or nothing like that because we never did.
We're always a little bit low-bought in citizens.
We knew your body.
We come up and our elders will tell us what certain things you can do.
Certain things you can't do this and not for you.
Just don't do that because they were basically trying to keep us out of trouble.
And trouble needed to get into.
Because one time I was me in three of my civil right workers was coming out of the restaurant at Agna Cafe.
And I walked out of the cafe and somebody was on the side of me in the dark and hit me with some weapon.
And from that incident me and my three workers we were charged with attempted murder of three waitresses in the restaurant that worked there.
66, I think.
It's 66.
And if I, you can tell me if this is right or not, I read that when you were attacked in an effort to fight back a gun was discharged and later the authorities pushed you with the attempted murder on the staff inside the restaurant.
That's right.
That's exactly how that happened.
And the amazing thing about it when I got who arrested me was my two classmates.
It's saying two blanks in half to get employed.
That's the way it worked out.
What they were doing, what they were told to do, they were doing their duties.
It's after a take a time.
I want to come back to a lot of these things.
I know that you must have had a very interesting, well I'd love to hear about, you had mentioned Mrs. Hex and your relationship before.
I'd love to hear about that.
I'd love to hear about your perspective watching your husband move into the deepens and watch all that history unfold in front of him.
And you're all inside all of that.
We were partners.
When they beat him, I was in Coventon, Louisiana.
I taught school there.
And when I came home, they had arrested the car too.
So his head was all swollen and incidentally we were the only family that were involved in civil rights that could go to a doctor in Boga-Lusa.
Everybody else had to leave town.
And why was that?
Because they knew we were small.
So when I got home, he was swollen up with a car.
We didn't have a warrant at that time.
And when they told me I could come get it, it was in a fire station right next to the police department.
And they had to door down.
That's a big heavy door.
And it was funny to the fireman, no black fireman there.
And I tried to pull the rope to get the hours weighed by 110 pounds.
And I couldn't open the door.
So I climbed up on top of the car, called a hole to the rope.
I swung down on it and sent the door flat.
I drove my car out.
The back window was out of the vehicle.
And came home.
I really...
I was held back.
Because I'd been in jail somewhere.
Mrs. Hicks, we both are calm in fact to me.
Because I wanted somebody to do something.
I wanted to get them back.
She was like, no, no, don't do that.
And she would talk me out of a violent act most of the time.
In my family, when you were four years old, you were taught how to shoot.
And you were taught how to swim.
When you made nine, you were given your own rifle.
And I can remember when I was in a wagon as a little girl.
And my dad would take us hunting.
And we'd stay and play around the wagon and he'd go hunting.
But right then, I'm a hunter.
I'm alive.
Were you...
What did you think about your husband joining the decals?
All of the advice that other people gave me, leaving.
You're just going to get yourself killed and get your children killed.
I have not my way.
I believed in what they believed in.
If you don't defend yourself, who do you think will?
I want to ask you both for your feelings and recollections of the early 65 rubber hits,
scale Jenkins and Easy Young will take...
Basically take control of the voters.
Yes, right.
And Andrew Moses resigns and will stop one second.
He lost a life.
We'll stop for a second.
Just pause for a second.
We're alive.
I'll just put the question back again.
Mr. Sanders, I'm very interested in your thoughts and reflections about early 65 when younger folks,
including Easy Young and Robert Hicks and Gail Jenkins, effectively take control of the vote of the voters.
Andrew Moses has resigned.
There are a lot of conflicting opinions and perspectives on what's the best course to pursue civil rights and both.
Some other folks have some opinions.
There are a lot of different range opinions.
You mentioned a moment ago, for example, that some people advised you, your friends even advised you to stay clear of the decals and direct involvement.
Could you talk a little bit about the various opinions that were in the community at that time and how different people thought about trying to pursue civil rights?
Well, if words, the black population was concerned, the black community, a lot of them were afraid because they are never stood up for opposition against the wider step.
They were afraid.
And they were afraid that they knew who was in power.
The police were in power and they would come in and hope them, some of them worked in the houses, other people.
That's the honest, implombative head.
And they were afraid that somehow they was going to get fired.
They couldn't work at factories or nothing.
They didn't hire them.
They went hire them as store.
They were maids in these houses.
And when you tell my picket it and go on into restaurants and eat that the same counter, they were afraid.
They were afraid.
And they didn't know.
They were just confused, though, which direction to take.
Then when A.G. commented the boldest boldest day, I was very pleased with it because we worked together.
We worked in the same department at the plant.
So I've known him and he was never elected.
He just commented the boldest boldest day again.
And I would say acted that product that because he was never elected that product that.
But he did act as Bobpix, your techie that Bobpix come with him.
And both of them worked at the plant with me.
But I worked with A.G. I knew Bobpix worked there, but I didn't really know him.
I see him, but I didn't know him.
But I knew A.G. from time to time.
But A.G. used to be in a taxi business.
He owned tax cabs.
And I had worked for him during that kick of time.
And we worked together on the job.
So that was very...
Mrs. Jenkins, I didn't know Mrs. Jenkins at that particular time.
I know when we met with a late-owned one,
Ebbers was elected governor of the state of Louisiana.
He appointed Gales Jenkins on the school board.
And he appointed RT Young, which was A.G. Brothers to the school board.
And that's when I began to know something about her.
Yeah.
But I didn't really know her.
And most of the position that we got on the city council in the school board,
they were the appointed position.
They were not elected.
Then after we followed and went to court,
they started redistricting.
And again, the black community of Montreal,
in the population where a black person could be elected.
And from that, Mrs. Jenkins got re-elected to the school board,
also RT Young.
And we got out for a city elected official,
which was William Bayley and Michael Richmond,
but the first two.
They were first appointed.
And then after they were redistricted,
they were able to get elected by the black community.
And that's in that redistrict still stand.
That's the only one.
The same two that they had given that it was appointed is the same two.
That's not the same two people, but the same two positions.
There's nothing changed.
City council, nothing changed.
Nobody had never been elected at large,
over the internet.
Who did this?
Black fraction of both the population.
That's right.
Well, we had established ourselves on the north side of town.
And when...
As a young couple?
Not young.
No, sorry.
When you said you established yourself on the north side?
Within the 60s.
I was in the 80s when this happened.
When we became aware, this was what was happening.
We had to re-register.
We had to change our vote in place.
And when we got our cards back,
they had him in District D and me in District C.
So I went down in the community
and asked people to give me the cards.
And when they showed me,
just about everybody on the street,
they lived in the same house.
But they had them voting in different districts.
And this was one of the ways they used to help keep us
from being a power for one particular candidate.
So...
Yeah.
Man, I see Mrs. Anshed.
I'm interested...
You mentioned your friendship with a meeting in the sex for the first time.
I'd like to hear about that relationship.
So we're interested in any thoughts you can share about...
This was a movement in her boat.
It was a very strong...
Very strong leadership.
And very strong leadership, both from women and from men.
How interesting your thoughts about how women played their roles in this history?
This is one of the few communities where...
And the black women had a voice.
The men didn't try to keep them from talking or being involved.
In fact, the majority of the time,
when they were taking care of back-and-bidges or something like that,
when a person gets through talking to them,
they turn an extra wife, what you think.
Or sometimes the wife would be the person to pay attention
and explain to him what we say.
So it was just an honor, my thing, for black women to step up to the plate.
What can you tell me about Dale Jenkins?
I wanted to ask him to help somebody many years later to know what's really the essential things to know about.
Ms. James, what would you say?
I would say that she was a fireball.
She would get excited and older people liked her.
And they would do what she said to her.
When Gail was a senior, I know where not a senior.
When she was elected Miss Central,
I was in the second grade and I was a part of her court.
So I had known Gail for a long time.
She worked at a Despoit Clinic.
And her aims wasn't high.
See, in our community,
you didn't have romance.
And I remember her saying one time,
her role, my heart,
intention, and life was the way I went to the phone.
Go to work at some white person's house
and bring the newspaper home under her arm
when she got out of work and eating it.
But when it came about,
when civil rights came about in Buggalooza,
it just opened up like a flower for her.
She and some more women
when Willie Boyle Crawford first wanted to
desegregate Votec.
Gail Jack, a whole bunch of ladies went to school at
two years old.
Four years later,
was when I met them again from childhood
to then.
By this time I'm working in Coventon.
I said, what you majored in?
They told me.
I said, they don't take for two years for that.
They've been there for
from what they were doing.
They were at courses today for every time.
Well, every year they did it after the two years.
And so they had attended school for four years
and they never did graduate from Votec.
So then they had to drive to New Orleans
or to a poplar beer to school
and they became nurses.
Yeah.
Let me ask you about the deans.
Your recollections of the leadership folks at Charles Senns.
Mr. Moore.
And how...
Well, let me start with that.
I'm sorry. Let me start with...
If you would, I'd love your...
Charles Senns from that meeting that we had with the group from John Burr.
Charles Senns was elected president of the Deacon for defense.
Robert Hicks was vice president from that meet.
Charles Senns appointed me lieutenant from that meet.
I've known Charles for a long time.
He first, he had worked at the same plant that I worked at.
And he got laid off, he got in a...
a ball, him and another white employee.
And Charles Senns hit him with a hammer.
And he dismissed him.
And I'd been known him for a long time.
And he was a fire reperson.
He was a fire reperson.
He could...
Arouse a crowd.
He had...
He was very intimidating person.
And he did a great job as president of the Deacon for defense.
And he was known with Robert Hicks, which was the vice president.
Robert Hicks had occasion to travel.
We went to California, raising money for the bullies of Rotterly.
We were very successful in doing that.
And Robert Hicks worked.
Showed that we walked picket together.
We marched together.
We did...
Give out everything together.
And...
But you're all seeing with a great leader.
A great leader.
Along with Sam Barnes and Skipper Piper.
And they were...
They were tough...
Perkins.
Reese Perkins.
And...
Willa Jane Preston.
They were there.
And...
But trainwite.
Albert Davis.
He was...
They were one of the...
Some of the key members of the Deacon.
What if that?
Let me ask you to think back to that first meeting again.
February 65.
Because I wonder if you...
I wonder if you...
If you...
The Baltimore members of the Deacons ever knew that they're...
The state authorities...
Had an informant in that meeting.
I wish you did.
Yeah.
I did.
You did it.
Yeah.
Because a couple of days later all those names were in the law enforcement files and on the
governor's desk, etc.
And I just...
I...
I wouldn't know.
Yeah.
Where'd that tell the informant?
I sure wouldn't.
I heard about one...
I didn't...
Not in that meeting.
I didn't know.
I didn't know how to...
Yeah.
Conception, did you ever...
Did you want to say something about that?
No, other than...
He was a...
A planning both...
Organization.
I don't know how I got it.
But...
Usually I can tell a crew...
Yeah.
You were at the time or at the later?
No, at the time.
And it would seem like...
When you voice that opinion about somebody...
People kind of...
Look at you.
So you have to be careful who you said, too.
But I didn't say it to some people.
He's a crew.
Yeah.
Mr. Anderson, I know that some of the many of the folks who were...
Among the list of men you just mentioned,
many of them had military experience.
And so they had, obviously, like training with firearms and so forth.
Other folks like yourself and other...
Month and all their lives.
And then shotgun rifle was very familiar.
Can you describe some of the...
Some of the ways you organized your work.
I know that you use special flashlight signals.
You mentioned walkie talkies.
That's right.
Walkie talkies.
We...
We also bought weapons...
To defend ourselves, which are carbines.
And we got thirty-thirty.
And we had handguns and stuff like that.
We bought some of that stuff with the money that we raised.
And people bought...
Broad and and donated to us.
So people like Lewis Low-Mac and other people from California brought...
And we used old phones to arm ourselves.
The people that didn't already have one.
We had people like Willie Jane Preston and all had served in the military.
And they were fired on mixed works.
And they had other people that even much would not...
A member of the DICAM, but they will show you how to do certain things.
Because they were afraid to be known.
And they were spread of what would happen to them.
And they found it, but they would secretly show us how to do things.
How to organize things.
How to help us in all the way.
People that never mentioned, you know,
because they were wanted to not be mentioned.
How many members would you say would have been publicly recognized?
Excuse me.
May I take a break?
Yes, please.
Let's take a break.
Can you just talk that microphone off your glass?
I mean, there's a little metal thing inside.
We're going to come back on.
Okay.
Let me ask about the right in the middle of the summer of 65.
And things really kind of come to the fullest point of tension.
The clan has been really fighting hard to try to beat back the...
any signs that the movement might move forward.
And the league is pushing real hard, marching and marching, marching.
Do you remember how you felt in those months?
Did you feel optimistic?
Did you feel fearful?
Did you feel...
I mean, you might have felt many things, no longer.
What it was like to go through that?
What we felt is how long it was going to take before we started seeing a change.
You know, how long we were going to have to...
So we were doing all this marching, all this fighting.
We said I had to work for a little.
And it was heated when you go to work, when you go into their workplaces.
And we had to travel to different places.
And then we had to deal with the police up and down the highways.
And they threw fools and all that.
They began tickets.
They gave it a pull over.
You don't know.
You'll always be obedient to the law.
You know, regardless of what you have, they are the law.
You have to...
You have to honor the law.
And respect her.
Although knowing that they were upholding the law,
they were just doing things to make everything difficult.
We were getting tickets several times to pay them.
You're record with the insurance company and insurance company dropping you.
Because you get traffic tickets and all this kind of stuff dropping you.
Because of your cars, your homes, and your life insurance.
It was tough.
But we were determined.
We weren't going to be stopped.
We was going to make a difference.
In the city of Bolus and in the state of Louisiana.
There were no black state troops in the state of Louisiana.
We marched to Badger and got a state of black state troops.
We were a side.
So we opened up door to door.
And some of the surrounding towns saw what was happening in Bolus
and they didn't want to go through the same thing.
They started opening up to the black community.
And hiring them and opening up some doors for them.
And other areas.
But they were tough.
We think back again on the deacons and your work to protect black communities.
Is there any one episode or a couple episodes that really come first to your mind
when you think about that as a particular interesting or particularly memorable significance moment?
Well that's for the next moment when we were marching from we have been to the Kodas.
We had come back and one of the clansmen attacked the moors, somebody in the moors.
And he had to be shot.
And that was something we was hoping that nothing like this had to happen.
But it was a case of self defense and what you have to do.
And so much when me and my two fellow workers were arrested for this.
They were thrown out of court.
There were there were there's put charges on you and brain things on you that they knew
couldn't stand up in the court a lot.
And we were fortunate enough to have Eli and Robert and I.
And and of Neil Eli and Robert to come down and fight our case.
And and they just throw that out of court.
They never never went anywhere.
And it's that particular time there was the three of the highest bond that were being in Washington, Paris.
You're 75,000 dollars on each account.
Well, we're 25,000 dollars that told you.
They arrested me.
I was coming home from work.
I stopped behind a school bus.
It wouldn't used to have a railroad track when you just you got on 21.
It was a state trooper behind me.
I rode behind me and I was behind the bus.
They never stopped the bus.
Until we got to Wall-Hand.
Wall-Hand Louisiana.
He pulled me over.
He said, I handed my driver's license.
He said, where you going?
I said home.
I live in Bucalusia.
He said, do you work?
I said, yes, I do.
Do you work?
Yes, I do.
Follow me.
Did you turn and follow him to jail?
They put me in jail.
Locked me up.
My bond was $4.00.
I had it.
I called Fletching and told him I was in jail.
Come get me.
And he came to Coventon and picked me up.
That charge was never taken to the next level.
It was just a harassment.
I'm pretty sure I understand the point you're making about his repeated questions.
But for the recording, can you say why you think that?
Because I would not say yes, sir.
I'm about to do that.
And when I got in the jail, I was in the jail with a young lady in the house fixed.
I'm going to my aunt and she asked me, would I please not?
Because they would make it hard for her after she left.
And they tried to make a haul for me going in there, but I got on in there.
It's real good.
Mr. Allen, Mr. Allen, let me...
You mentioned the shooting in July of 65.
Can you describe that situation a little more to tell why it was,
how that happened?
We were just marching.
They were hectic on the sides.
They got a gas shot, was slaying racial slurs.
And everything got to Mars.
Then quite not just a few guys slung back at him.
And when it were giving back at him, he did something that he couldn't take.
He just dashed towards the Mars.
But that one guy hit him.
He got shot.
You have a real awesome shot.
Now it was Milton.
Put him in a car with him.
Milton.
It was another guy.
Milton Johnson's with him.
Milton Johnson.
That's right.
Milton Johnson was getting attacked by the law.
Milton Johnson.
Oh, had it too.
Was that when they attacked had it?
The little girl.
Yeah, had it.
And I remember one occasion we was picking it on public property.
I mean, Robert Hicks and a bunch of more of us.
And they arrested us.
And put us in school bus and killed us at St. Tamin' Day.
Well, the bus broke down, threw the rod on the way to St. Tamin' Day.
So we had to set it on the bus and wait till they brought another bus.
And that was one of the detectives.
It was one of the things where we was on public property.
Nobody, no private property.
Nothing came of that bus load of us.
Nothing came of that.
No charge, no fines, no nothing.
It's been a long-distance.
It was me for it.
Our lawyers come in and got everything.
It's me.
We just walked out of jail.
That was it.
Never heard no more about it.
Let's take a little call on St. Tamin.
Well, you know, some of the people that were there, how would you tell them that?
Yeah, well, some of the people, like I say, were with us.
Was Willie Jane Preston.
And his brother Oliver Preston.
And they were very, very active in the move.
There was women like Helen Jefferson.
A guy by name was Jane Brown.
And they were Canadian Griffith.
And they were very, very men.
Canadian Griffith was the one that used to pick up Jane Farmer from Corp when he come in.
And we would pick him up from the airport.
We would protect him while he was here.
We would protect his workers, the core workers, the civil right workers while he was here.
Mace, you know, danger come to him.
That was Canadian Griffith in my job.
That's what we were assigned to.
And all the top people that would come in, we were the one that watched them.
We were the one that protected.
Canadian Griffith in there myself during that time.
And he was, Canadian Griffith attacked on Columbus Street in front of Windixie.
Windixie was on Columbus Street.
They beat him up pretty badly.
And nothing was ever come to that.
Any time that something would happen to a black person, they would never do anything about it.
We had one idea of friends, museums coming from the military, Captain Seymour,
making a phone call in a phone booth right there on Columbus Street,
playing the shot in a phone booth.
Nothing, Maca-Mayor had to come to Boa-Luisa to see if nothing never happened to that.
And we were this open game.
And he much with the protection that we were given.
Some people come down like Seymour, he went away out of what was happening here.
And he went to the phone booth, Maca-Mayor called all of this happened to him.
He is in the military fighting for this country and get shot.
Yeah, they'll do one thing.
Can you share your recollections of folks in Corps and the collaboration between the League and Corps?
It was great. It was great.
They was a life saver to us.
And it came, it was a lot of knowledge too, because they were for Mars and Demonstrates and all that kind of thought.
They were very knowledgeable of what to do and how to do it, and how to stay out of harm's way.
How to protect yourself.
They were very loud. And Jane from, I don't know what we did that meant for him.
I have so much respect for him.
And Dick Gregory and all of them, they would come in and they would help us.
They would help us to raise money and do, and have to keep the movement going.
You Dick Gregory was a life saver too. You were very helpful too.
They talked to black people, or popular stuff, how to stop a pattern that had been set or established.
And instead of buying a Cadillac by a both-way, and drive that until you could buy your Cadillac, you could afford it.
They emphasize, don't make the other man fat off your label.
That your label worked for you.
And as far as Dickens are concerned, when we won't outweigh the Baton Rouge, we got to Hamlin.
On March, on the road?
Yes.
And we decided we were going to spend a night in the park, in Greenville Park.
And that's where the football field was for Black High School.
And the police department, the sheriff department, came down from Hamlin from Tenshville, O'Parrison, told us that we could not stay there.
That that was private property.
So we told the police that, okay, we'll march up to Southeast and University and we spend the night there.
We paid taxes.
So that's somewhere we can't spend a night.
Well, they discussed it and they decided it was all right to stay in the park.
We circled the cars in the park like the wagons and the Indians.
And they sent state troopers.
Now, the state troopers were there to guard us, not protect us.
And we spent the night in the park.
But the next morning they went to search all the black people's cars.
And that was the one time that I was proud as a Dicas Cossi.
When we were on at March, we didn't have, people would let us use the Baton.
We couldn't drink water.
We had to provide all our own needs.
So Mr. Wilde built a latrine on the back of a truck.
And he and his wife drove the latrine that's Bernadine's mama and daddy.
The...
When we came out of that march and I came out of the park and headed toward the Baton
Rooie, they sent me home.
The rest of me headed toward Baton Rooie's.
But when I went that way the next day, they had tax.
It's thick as rocks, for miles on that walkway.
On that Rooie going to Baton Rooie's.
Client and put down all that, almost 10.
Yep.
Did you...
What was your sense of the clan in the community after finally the federal government came in
and really came down on the lawsuit?
And did you have a sense that things had shifted in an important way or no?
But on the thing you have at that point, they were...
Someone was exposed.
We knew who they were.
You know, they was identified.
The federal government had identified.
Because some of my work with...
Oh, my job.
And some of them was...
My...
Supervised.
When you know you that you're supervised as a client, and he did.
And you could see him taking up money to send to the...
to help the Cluco clan and to fight out here and the streets of the state.
And you work in there and you have to take all this from you, supervised, whatever you tell you you have to do.
And you got to respect him, whatever.
As telling you what to do, you have to respect that.
Because we don't do that.
They need to do your job.
We can't support your family.
And we have to always keep that in mind too.
Always keep that in mind too.
At the workplace.
But one thing about who I work with, all is what you did outside the plant.
That was your business loan.
You were able to report back to work.
They didn't penalize you for what you did outside of the plant.
That's your business.
We could do anything we wanted to do for our activity for March.
And they might hold it, but they couldn't take your job from that.
They didn't do that.
Because you didn't do that.
That's why we had a scrum.
But if they took the time we had two years, we had a white year and a black year.
And there are some of the things that we were able to do that.
Merges that make it one.
Through the loss of the plant.
Yeah.
And that made it, when we all come together, that made things a lot easier.
It didn't help education though.
That's a great point.
And I want to ask that woman.
I take you back.
You were shaking your head a moment ago when I asked the question,
did it feel like much had changed?
Have federal government come down on the client?
And you were shaking your head?
No.
In Bogalosa, when they make an announcement, you could tell from the location whether it's
black folk and a team.
You're not welcome.
All they want you to do is shop in town.
And that's the most essential way the community can really change through the 60s and beyond.
It's just town, dad, to keep from changing.
Literally, dad.
You would see the street, drive down the street.
He's dead.
For the education, to my knowledge is that at first, he was separate.
You know, we were getting books to come from the white school.
But when we integrated, we still don't, we read not the same book we have in math and everything.
It's the same.
But we own the same level.
From that point, I think things are better.
But although we, my first last regulation was we are 60-40 in the school system, black
kids.
60% black, 40% white.
But we're not in control or nothing.
You know, the school, but it's predominantly white.
The principals and system principals and everybody in the thought is predominantly white.
So even some of the whites in Bowel's hash sent their children to the parlor.
They won't even send them to public school because they said they can't get a good education in a system
because they don't say they quit teaching.
That's what they're being said.
They quit teaching.
They quit teaching anybody.
So they send them.
They owe them up a lot of private schools.
In the city of Kiesa, private school because they don't trust the public school system.
And by integrating, we kind of own the same level for us being in the same school, the same books.
And it helped the relationship of the young people with each other.
They can see what their parents are told down through these.
That's not so.
That's not the kind of people they are.
They are good people.
They come from good home.
They are this.
And that relationship with them is a lot better.
And I think that comes from the integration of the school system.
They hired a lot of teachers that are not qualified.
You got the biggest group when you go to a college graduation is the dual education people.
And when they came out, looked like all of them gained a book.
And got hired.
Now, when they first used to go to school, white teachers who could not stand the thought of teaching black kids retired.
Some teachers stayed and they could not stand the thought of teaching black kids.
And they talked to white kids and they changed the method of teaching.
Teachers used to stand in front of the class and teach everybody and everybody learned.
After these segregation, the teachers had to walk up and down the aisle and pay attention to individual students and correct them.
They did not correct the black kids.
They just continued to go wrong.
Then they would end up in a village, special education and more than that.
All of these things hindered true education.
And it's still hindered.
Do you have final thoughts?
We haven't talked about our relaying.
Do you have thoughts?
Do you have the last issues or what?
I actually do.
Because we do everything different.
If you could change anything that you do, it's like changing.
I could change anything.
What I would like to see that it comes a time when we see each other as a person.
When they're not in color of the skin, not anything to do that.
We would see a person as a person for what he is.
Before I would, and that's what I would like to see.
That's a change that I would like to see.
Will I ever see it?
I guess seem like there going to always be racism.
I guess there will racism from the time that the country will never, ever form.
I can see it every day and then news for me here.
I can see it every day in the bubble.
At the workplace, what makes it, I don't know.
But I tell you one thing.
We're going to fight to make, try to make a change.
We're going to fight to try to make a change.
All these changes that we have made so far, I know it was just a help of the good Lord
that kept us here because we have been in some battle.
We need much that much to bad news.
We have to, it will fight all the way there.
And it got so bad at one time, we got to have where there they wanted us to go.
Take 55 and go up through them with comb and come back home.
And at that time, we still stayed true for that.
We had to die on the highway.
We had to die the way we come down.
That's the way we're going back.
And we decided to come back that way.
And there was shots with fire that was coming back.
And what we made it back, we made it back.
And we never did back up for no regardless of the circumstance.
We didn't back up for them.
We were all out of that.
I'm just so proud of the confidence that I was able to work alongside of A.D. Young, Robert Hicks and Charles Sam,
to make a difference in Bogolosa and in the state of Louisiana.
And there are women like myself, Mrs. Hicks and Mrs. Jenkins, that were the part of Mrs. Y, that were the part of this.
The Scrooge women, Scrooge women that made a difference.
Scrooge women that had the husband back when they went on that.
Scrooge women that protected the children and marched them to school when they were the first black to go into the school.
And they had to protect them while they're husband at work.
They showed that no danger come to them.
And we definitely got some Scrooge black women in this time.
And some of them still in the school system, still fighting to make education better for the blacks and the white.
Because the black women is still teaching.
They still are teaching.
Because they know everybody needs to education.
Whether you black or whether you white, you need to need to education.
And the less educated is where you basically go and find the clooker of clay.
Because educated person most have more knowledge and education than sense to do the things that the less educated, clandered up.
Educated person very well, is going to drag you down the street behind a car, a lent you.
They're not going to do that.
But the less educated person will.
And that's why education is so important.
It is the key to racism, my thing.
It's the key to America being a better American than it is.
And we need education.
We have to scribe, to have education, whatever we do.
And this...
And one other question, in your response.
A number of people who were involved in the civil rights movement have talked about their great disappointment.
And young people have not taken up the ballot and found areas where they could create change and make a difference themselves.
What's your thinking about the role of young people today?
That's a question that troubles all of us.
Either...
Now some of those young people don't know nothing about the movement.
And we do as much as we can to get to history out the same thing y'all doing that.
And the more knowledgeable they become, hopefully they will get involved in it.
But some have said that drugs were planted in the community.
Drug were planted in the community by the policemen and their failed agencies have been told.
I know it's here.
I get here, I know, I don't know black parts of hell, I know where I get in here.
And it feeds their drugs in the community.
And they get hung up on drugs and that's all they look for.
They got these teen pregnancies that there's no man in their home.
And that makes a difference.
That makes a difference.
And they're not doing the thing that we figure they should be doing.
They make life better because they get...
If they trap in poverty, some of them had got what they don't see no way out.
And for some reason they think that if they could stay high on drugs,
stay in the situation that they are in, that they're going to survive.
But that's not what's going to happen.
Either you're going to get your education, you're going to come out to the situation,
or you're in or you're going to die in poverty.
You will not...
To be a leader, to help, you have to have a education.
You have to have a education.
And some of the young blacks that have went on to have a education,
and I think they think if they make a wave, it will interfere with their life.
If I'm doing pretty good, I'm not going to reach back and help nobody else.
If I'm got a commercial or something when it comes to athletes,
I'm not going to speak out against anything.
That's going to take the good, easy road for myself and my family.
But that's not the way we are.
That's not the way to see a right where based them.
That's not the way Martin Luther King, that's not the way the rest of us had to.
He's a young, a flexion, a robin, a hicks.
That's not what I was thinking.
You got to help somebody else.
Regardless, life is not worth living.
If you can't think of something you did to make life better for somebody else.
I think we all put him for a purpose.
That purpose is to have life better for yourself and somebody else in your family.
They make this world better place, delivering them when you found it.
Make it better.
My children are supposed to have more than I have.
They're children are supposed to have more than they have.
We're supposed to grow, not sing.
But if somebody in the black-tailed droves say,
God, I'm whether this comes stagnated right where they are.
They don't choose to move.
But hopefully, they'll put y'all through, through history through.
What they can see, what the other blacks have achieved during their scrubber,
what still left to be achieved, they will step up to the plate and start doing something.
I hope I can live to see that then.
I hope I can live to see.
I've got one final question.
When you think back on the Bogulus movement,
could it ever have taken the form that it did without the real capacity in the community for self-defense?
I don't think so.
Because we have to be able to, for the community to say that that was somebody going to protect them.
That they could go to bed knowing that somebody was out there protecting them.
That they weren't going to be drug out of their houses.
They weren't going to be killed.
The children weren't going to be immatial or those types of situations happening to them.
Once they knew that, they were able to come out and go to their jobs
and come back.
A lot of them suffered.
A lot of got laid off because they come out of their maid business and someone without...
That was the only sinkerm that they had.
Because someone didn't have us.
They made some for two.
But without the dickermod of the fancy, of course, no.
It couldn't have stood.
The clan in Washington, Paris,
is a powerful, there's any population in the world.
Population side is as strong as anybody else in the world.
And that's still exists.
That's still exists.
That's not on a three-piece suit and a tie.
That's a different style of them.
But the fear is gone.
The fear is gone out of the like people of the Cooke-Cocland.
That fear is gone.
There's no more fear.
The dickermod took the fear out of it because they told them that the same bullet that a kill you,
the same bullet that a kill somebody else.
There are no different beds, don't they?
But it also showed you that you don't look for trouble.
All you do is protect yourself.
Protect yourself.
And so forth that's been happening here.
We have very few killings.
We have a black killing of us.
Our thing is black on black crime.
We have a lot of that.
We've been working with that.
And it's not as much here as in other places.
Very seldom has happened here.
I think it used to be if a white kill or white,
they'd go through the black community beating up the black men.
And we've been able to keep that black on black crime down tremendously in this city.
That is one of the things that I think a lot about.
I'm very proud of.
And talking to the young black people is something that we constantly do.
And our churches and our communities and everybody else to make things better.
Right now, Bogolos is trying to get one YMCA.
You know, they had a black one and a white one.
Now they're coming together to get one.
That's the first time this ever been did in the history of Bogolos.
In all other cities, you probably see that one.
But all go the same.
But here, the still got a black one and a white.
And it's a 2011.
It's a 2011.
Well, thank you, good Lord.
Thank you for the Lord, the disco, Brain Valley Chain.
Brain Valley Chain.
I really want to thank you both so much.
The half of all the folks involved in the project has been a real privilege and honor to be with you.
Thank you both so much.
Thank you all.
Appreciate it.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.